okay calculator fanciers we've got a
great one to unbox on numberphile today
hi my name is Matt Parker and I'm gonna
be looking at this natural bamboo
calculator look at that bamboo solar
calculator and you can see on the front
there it is clearly a calculator made of
bamboo if you look on the back you can
see it says the woods natural and bamboo
and there's a calculator the big two
features of this are that it's a
calculator and it's made of bamboo and
in fact it breaks down while it's
featuring unique elegant design I think
the word unique there is pretty much
beyond debate ful bamboo construction I
assume they're not referring to the
circuitry inside large display twelve
digital's that's a bit like having
twelve digits but twelve digital's are
even better so let's say get in there
and see it this calculator that is made
of bamboo so again we're gonna take our
overly sharp scalpel we're gonna cut
through the base of the box that's to
leave the top of it in a mint-condition
there we are so that's that open oh look
at that already you can see there that
is a piece of bamboo look at that okay
so we'll now get the rest of it out oh
look at that that is a calculator made
of bamboo I don't know what I was
expecting other than a calculator made
of bamboo but it really is that's that
is fantastic okay we lost we getting
nothing no instructions I mean what more
do you need you've got you've got the
word bamboo you've got a picture of a
chemical at it that's all you need to
know about this so there it is that's
ambu calculator let's fire it up
look at that little zero there cuz I've
turned it on there's the solar power
which is powering it and if I cover that
up you can see that it is starting to
fade that's because insufficient
batteries in there which is not good
although we can there are screws on the
backs we could pop it open and have a
closer look maybe we'll do that later
you can see here that the edge around
the frame is all made of bamboo to the
back here this is made of bamboo you can
see the buttons here they're all a made
of bamboo there's a reoccurring theme
there's a lot of bamboo
on here blitz let's know bamboo aside
let's see how it functions as a
calculator so what are the old classic
1/9 should give me a 9th if I multiply
that by 9 it should go back to 1 which
it doesn't let's try if it does the
correct order of operation
so we'll do 5 plus 2 times 5 if it's
correct we get 15 if it's wrong we're
gonna get 35 35 it is wrong so it cannot
do order of operations we'll try some
errors we'll do 1 divided by 0 and we
get 0 well that's settled that debate
amongst mathematicians if you divide by
0 the answer it turns out is just 0 so
so far not great on maths but it does
use the slightly more accurate square
shaped decimal point over the circular
dot shaped decimal point and you can't
do square roots you can't do anything
else other than adding subtracting
multiplying and dividing which is plenty
although percent so it can tell you how
how percentage you are at any point in
time which is quite nice and the on is
the same as the clear I mean what a
wonderful philosophical ass but I guess
it goes with the whole general vibe of
the net that turning things on again is
like the rebirth which is the same as
just clearing where you were up to
but they've I mean this oh okay that
should probably be putting numbers on
the screen but it's it's okay I probably
haven't I've not cleared from my
previous calculation that's a different
0 now right so that's what they've
actually done ok the two different types
of it that's the normal 0 there and if
you divide by 0 you get a different type
of 0 that's so no I mean there was me
making fun of it and it turns out it's
smarter than I thought so I mean the
might the main thing is even if the
answers aren't quite correct the
important thing is around them is a thin
layer of bamboo because in fact the
entire calculator is of course made of
bamboo this is the only calculator that
you could safely feed to a panda bear
that that's important to bear in mind
you you have to give a calculator to a
panda this is the one that they could
also use to calculate and to eat and in
fact giving this to a parent or E the
chance they would have of course of
multiplying scores for the natural
bamboo calculator the display while
small has got bamboo around it I'm gonna
give it a 6 functionality a mere 2
accuracy a one-er gonna makes a 3 you
can after all get splinters off it cred
3 depends very much on the environment
where you're using it and in terms of
durability
well there you are despite being made of
wood it actually hasn't caught on fire
I'm gonna give it a durability score of
8 which makes for a grand total of 23 an
average score of 3.8 3 reoccurring
bamboo bamboo banboot banboot banboot
banboot banboot banboot banboot banboot
banboot banboot the bamboo bamboo bamboo
and bamboo bamboo bamboo